at coach Billick on Twitter the Super
Bowl winning head coach from the
Baltimore Ravens back here on the
program how are you coach good morning
what's the strangest pregame fire-up
speech you have ever heard from a team
captain or a quarterback coach oh wow
you know I had some pretty good ones you
know Ray Lewis would come to me maybe
three times a year and say let's go let
me because I mean coach let me take this
one which I defer to very quickly
absolutely you know he was strategic
about it and he would have some fired up
that would yeah yeah we get me going
pretty good
I had one old-time players tell me when
when that kinda lost it when when George
Allen's told him hey we'd win this game
I would give up my firstborn child for a
win today he said okay wait maybe we've
we've we've gone into that realm of
business not this is not rational
the e2w thing coach I mean what does
Dirk Koetter do when he sees that video
of that's what he said to his teammates
you could just see them looking at him
like what is he thinking coach I mean
what does Dirk cutter do after that and
Mike Evans goes at Marshawn Lattimore
and he's got to bench his quarterback
for ryan fitzpatrick and the season is
going down the tubes
two and six for an ownership that has
had an itchy trigger finger on multiple
occasions leading to him getting the job
for lovie smith what is he thinking
today do you think yeah this is a tough
one because and and and rich I do 20
shows a week of these cut you know that
the radio shows yep and in the cities
where you're just talking about whether
it's New York
whether it's Tampa Bay whether its
Cincinnati whether it's wherever you can
you can pick the hotspot where you start
the discussion about okay the coach is
losing the locker room all right now I'm
a coach so I'm gonna burrow up on that a
little bit coach doesn't lose the locker
room the locker room loses so no player
plays for a coach yeah you may like the
guy you may not like the guy you may
respect him or not you may believe what
he's doing or not but you're not playing
for a coach and so when I hear that a
lot you know coaches losing the locker
room No
they're losing themselves and and this
is just symptomatic and it's typical and
we're gonna stare typical we see it all
the time so the challenge for whether
it's obviously in New York and Tampa Bay
any of these teams that are struggling
that coach has got to you know jump on
it right away and in some with more
strength than others I mean it's an
institutional problem the institution
can drop it and say look this guy's not
going anywhere that gives the coach
latitude to say look guys one thing I do
know I'm gonna be here next year so the
question is are you and and you got to
show me over these next eight weeks why
should keep you on this team now if the
coach doesn't have that strength now
you're getting into it you're getting
into a tough dynamic so is Jameis
Winston a quarterback do you think they
can win in this league well I think
there are legitimate questions about it
we've seen signs of it but compared to
some of the other and where we talked
about this porridge I love where we're
at at the quarterback situation with the
young quarterbacks coming up in this
league you know we've been through times
when that transition from the you know
the the hall-of-famer is going into
what's the next group there's been a
little bit of a voice there was that a
little bit of that situation in 2000 we
want our championship but right now
however you view the old guard whether
it's Rogers Brady Roethlisberger Brees
on and on we got a group of good young
quarterbacks whether it's well obviously
we're seeing Carson Wentz and the growth
to Jared Goff and I like Mariota dak
Prescott and the light is Jameis Winston
in that group not yet because there are
some inconsistencies there that I'm not
ready to write them off as saying no but
there's some inconsistencies there that
have got to give you a concern before
you put it in that group of oh yeah this
this is a you group of young bucks
coming forward Brian Billick here on the
Rich Eisen show do you think the Giants
are gonna let Ben McAdoo decide whether
Eli Manning gets benched and take a look
at Davis Webb do you really think he has
that authority in New York
no any it's the best of circumstances
unless you're Bill Belichick that's an
institutional decision that's one that's
got to be made it all up
and and you could certainly understand
it but Eli Manning giving us even if
it's not someone at Eli Manning's level
you know this anytime you make a check
a quarterback for whatever the reason
because your your you're basically
saying and probably rightfully so okay
look we're done so we're playing for
next year and we got to answer some
questions for next year what do you
think pay or Eli Manning is going to be
your starting quarterback there or not
you got to find out you know do we need
to because we're going to be in position
sadly for one of these good young
quarterbacks that supposedly is coming
out we got to make a decision but we
want to be in that market or not or do
we have a guy on campus aka David Webb
that no we don't have to extend those
resources we so those questions have to
be answered and the only way you're
gonna answer them adequately is if David
Webb plays so afire to give you the
choice between three six and two teams
in the NFC to say which one is built to
go longer Vikings
Saints Rams we're gonna just blow the
Eagles out of the mix cuz they're eight
one and wences playing out of a skull
and Jo Jai he's now added that mix for
that defense it looks downright scary
which one you think that's a chance to
go long as Ram saints or Vikings here
had the fewest questions cuz you look at
the Saints as well as the defense was
playing Drew Brees is growing great
they're running the ball so they got
that pedigree is the defense for real
they're showing signs of it they're
better but I think that Phil has to be a
question mark
Minnesota what's quarterback situation
you know I got the defense it looks like
a pretty good all-around team in Deacon
Case Keenum or is it you know it does
Brad you know the new guys come in and
do you look at Bradford is he gonna be
back what about you know in Bridgewater
so there's enough questions there that
so I go with the Rams because I have the
fewest questions quarterbacks improving
running game looks solid defense was
very very good and they're special teams
and maybe the best in the NFL so they
have the fewest questions let's put it
that way it is remarkable I mean all the
Rams needed yesterday in MetLife was 13
points to surpass the previous season's
entire points total and they got 51 and
they have a half a season to go they are
going to obliterate whatever record is
sitting there for a 16 game points
improvement i what what is Sean McVeigh
done from your estimation I mean you
coordinated one of the greatest offenses
in the
this game Brian what do you think Shawn
McVeigh is doing and has been able to
pull all off
well he's pressing all the right buttons
he's got the right people doing it
obviously with Wade Phillips as
defensive coordinator John fossil as a
special teams coach so begin I'm a coach
so I'm not so gonna lean towards that
it's great coaching but when you look at
Jared Goff you talk about the point and
going from where he was to still a sub
hunt 500 throw year projected wise but
under 500 throws he's projected for over
4,000 yards he's at that 60% mark 26
touchdowns eight intercepts now we're
not going to slam dunk him in the Hall
of Fame over that but you've seen a
steady in fact I'm gonna do a thing on
playbook on Wednesday about Jared Goff
and how intelligently McVeigh has
brought him from when you look at early
in the year it was all boots and waggle
play-action and throw which you see and
then begin to progress a little bit into
a little bit more the drop back throw at
the top of the drop get you in a 5 and 7
steps but not drop throw at the top or
put the thing away so now where it's
okay more progression Reese so Sean
McVeigh gets a lot of credit for
bringing Jared Goff along in a very
systematic and programmable way from
game one to where we are now to where
that growth with minimal you know
minimal turnover that growth is getting
to the point where he can be clearly on
solid footing as one of the thoughts
quarterback from this league all right
before I let you go I guess you've got
let's take a look at these four and four
teams
you got the Redskins the Falcons and the
Cardinals in the NFC I mean which one do
you think has the ability to go on a run
here mean agent Peterson Randall ball 37
times yesterday they take on Seattle on
Thursday Night Football at home short
week Seattle just got beat by the
Redskins with Kirk Cousins and then the
Falcons I mean I don't know what's
happened with them hangover or not which
one do you think is got maybe a second
half run in them in the NFC you know
Arizona you liked what they did the
other night but come on San Francisco so
you know you got a qualifies a little
bit by the Redskins when you look at
them play and the way cousins was
playing I think Gregg Milewski is doing
a great job on the defense given the
personnel they have
you've wonder holiday four and four and
they're better than that because they've
done a player two I could be six and two
very easily that you can always say that
about every team and it's laughable when
you say it sometimes it's always like
the defensive coordinator to say well
you know other than those three plays
where we gave up 400 you know and
whatever yards we really did pretty good
but Washington's when I look at go you
know what they they're better than that
four and four record is Atlanta it's
just it's hard or hard to figure out
which Atlanta team you're going to get
they have the potential to be better
than that
so if you ask me outright because of
I've seen Washington on a more
consistent basis do more good things I'd
say Washington it's unbelievable isn't
it I mean Falcons are have a hangover
correct when you say it's it's official
yeah I mean what we say coming in if
they start out well fine they could put
it behind them well they start out
three-and-oh but they could have been
one and two weeks very easily and and so
we dismissed this going well ya know
they're they're no hangover they're fine
because they beat the Bears the Packers
in the line then they went you know on
this four-game scared beat the Jets now
they lose for the Panthers they've got
they've got the Cowboys and the Seahawks
coming we're gonna find out in the next
two weeks whether indeed there's a
hangover or we can officially say okay
no they just as much as they've tried
and said all the right things they
haven't gotten past this what happened
last February last one for you I'm sure
you heard on Sunday Night Football both
Tony Dungy and Rodney Harrison said the
Texans should reach out to Colin
Kaepernick ASAP let's just remove all of
the off the field questions all right
how quickly could could a coach get him
up to speed based on knowing him and
knowing the offense that the way deshaun
Watson was running it for Bill O'Brien
well you can get it up to speed but he's
not gonna be deshaun Watson he'll give
you a few things outside the pocket he's
not going to do in the pocket anywhere
close to what the Shaun Watson did
that's why people are hesitating on
Colin Kaepernick all the other stuff
aside given your premise serious
questions about Colin Kaepernick and
just how much he can't improve and how
much is left or how much damage has been
done based on the lack of progression
that he's had and and now with another
offense and if he comes in and struggles
he has shown no ability to be effective
within the pocket can he give you some
outside the pocket sure and that may be
what Houston needs right now just that
little bit of spur but but make no
mistake now you're he's not going to
give you a tenth of what you were seeing
in deshaun Watson previous to the
injuries always great chat with you
coach you take care of we'll chat soon
you got it Brian Billick check it out
again NFL playbook 6:00 Eastern on
Wednesdays on the NFL Network for more
Rich Eisen show tune to audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Rich
Eisen show app